sooner in 10 days the movie event of the
summer arrives what do we do we find
Captain America Civil War is that
triumphs in every way
it's remarkable everything a blockbuster
should be
you have a metal arm and he's awesome
dude
so that we do on time - summer finally
arrives
everyone yeah we don't really need to
start a conversation captain big fan
Captain America Civil War me sick
hey youtubers is Charlie so we got some
new spider-man footage Tom Hollands been
talking about the character in Kevin
Feige actually clarified a little bit
about their arrangement with Sony so
there's a lot of exciting stuff
happening you can see how they use
spider-man to control the tone of the
film like things were getting ready to
explode in this big airport battle and
they use spider-man to just open that
pressure valve hey cap
big fan caps reactions just priceless
like oh my god can you believe this guy
he's like a slightly less fangirl
version of Phil Coulson
I watched you while you slept that was
probably one of my favorite lines from
any Marvel movie ever thus far I'm
expecting a couple of Civil War moments
to top that and a couple of you have
probably already seen the movie they've
been releasing it internationally in
different dates so some countries are
getting it right now the United States
isn't getting it till next week so I'm
not gonna see it till next week
but Tom Holland talked a little bit
about trying to play spider-man as a kid
as opposed to the other movies that play
them a little bit more like an adult
trapped in a kid's body like you watch
the Tobey Maguire movies even the Andrew
Garfield movies and they get the powers
they get the speech great power great
responsibility so they have to grow up
really fast because they witness Uncle
Ben dying so it's like oh my god they
have all this tragedy so in that moment
even though they're still teenagers they
really stopped being kids like their
childhood ends right there this new
version of spider-man still manages to
capture some of that childlike energy
you know even though he's already gone
through his origin story don't worry if
you're getting tired of them redoing the
Uncle Ben's story we're not gonna see
that in the new spider-man movie either
and Kevin Feige actually clarified that
they have the best relationship with
Sony ever and Sony has been letting
Marvel control creative on the new
spider-man film they've really only just
started working on it so I mean it's
gonna be a lot of back and forth it's
not like it's gonna be a hundred percent
Marvel movie obviously Sony's gonna have
some creative input on the character but
essentially the way that Feige put it is
that all the creative is flowing through
Marvel first so they're the ones that
are pitching this like okay this is how
it's gonna go these are the beats these
are what the characters are gonna be
like but Sony still retains financial
control of the character so even though
it seems like Marvel has a lot of
control over the new Sony films Sony
still owns the character it's really
more of a creative partnership it's not
so much a financial partnership with the
exception of when he appears in cameos
and Marvel films the other real cool
thing is there are a couple post credits
scenes they've been confirming it there
is one that's been playing behind the
inner
national release I don't know if they're
gonna add a third post credit scene for
the United States or North America
release it just remains to be seen left
to wait till next week to find out but
there's at least two post credits scenes
one involving the Civil War characters
in another involving spider-man's
character which makes sense because it
helps promote the Sony film but if you
have seen the movie please don't post
spoilers about what actually happens
during those post credits scenes because
the movies coming out in a couple days
so most of us will just find out in a
couple days when we see it I'll talk
about them more whenever I do my
spoilery Easter egg videos those won't
post till like after Thursday or Friday
I'm seeing the movie on Thursday so I'll
post a non-spoilery review first because
even though this is like a shut up and
take my money situation a lot of people
won't get to see the movie for a couple
days after it officially comes out
everywhere but you probably heard
everybody's calling this like the best
Avengers movie so far but if you have
seen the movie please let us know in his
non spoilery way as possible what you
thought of it you know good or bad you
know even if you didn't like it that's
still totally cool even if it's the
greatest movie in the history of the
world they'll still be people that don't
like it which I know sounds weird
usually I assume things that are half
and half well this is like a Fantastic
Four situation when like 99% of people
just absolutely hate it but if you guys
haven't caught up
they just teased the big Civil War
crossover on agents of shield I'll be
posting that video at least by tomorrow
I'm a little bit behind on videos just
because it's been so much Game of
Thrones stuff the last couple days so be
sure to subscribe to get everything
there's a new episode of arrow later
tonight too I know we've been talking
about a lot of Game of Thrones recently
but there's like so much other big stuff
happening Captain America Civil War
there's a bunch of TV stuff happening
too while you guys wait for my next
video to post you can click here for
last night's episode of the flash and
you can click here to learn all about
Iron Man appearing in the new spider-man
film thank you so much watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight
you